VICTOR DAVIS HANSON: It's
not hysterical to say
that the COVID-19 quarantine and
mass national lockdown, which
we've never seen
in American history
despite our long
experience with plague,
encouraged the destruction of
the middle class in general
and the middle class business
person in particular.
And it championed or
enhanced or empowered
large corporations
that were vertically
integrated-- the Amazons,
the Targets, the social media
companies, the Zooms.
Now, how did that happen?
Well, think for a minute.
If you sold shoes, and
you were a small business,
you were shut down.
If you sold flowers,
If you had a small restaurant,
you were shut down.
If you had a small business
that repaired watches,
you were shut down.
If you sold phones, you
were often shut down.
And yet, you could
go into Walmart.
You could go into Target.
You could get something
to eat, fast food.
You could buy shoes.
You could buy socks.
You could buy anything.
And when you went into Walmart,
or you went into Target,
or you went into any
of these large chain
stores, what did you see?
You saw hundreds of
people congested in there.
It was very different
than the experience
of going in and opening a
door, the little bell rang.
There might have been
one or two customers.
You knew the small
business person.
You could say, to the small,
have you been vaccinated?
Have you had COVID?
All of that interpersonal
relationship
that's so innate to
small communities
and small businesses.
But whether by intent or
just accidentally or laxity,
we essentially said to the small
business person, you obey us,
and you're going to
shut down your business,
and you have no power to object.
You have no capital.
You have no vertical
integration.
You have no influence.
And then we said to
the large corporation,
people during this lockdown
will still need to have shoes.
They'll need to buy clothing.
They'll be need to buy food.
They'll need to buy durable
goods and appliances.
And we pick, we select you
to be the conveyor of that,
and you're exempt
from the lockdown
because we trust that you're
large, and you're efficient,
and you're wealthy, and we've
dealt with you in the past
through political PACs and
donations and influence.
And so it doesn't
take a conspiracy
to see empirically
that the middle class
and the middle
class businessperson
suffered enormously under COVID
lockdowns and quarantines.
And large corporations got
larger and more powerful
and more dangerous.
[MUSIC PLAYING]